well let's put the positive snackdown on
some headlines let's do it so I have to
ask you a fashion question Vogue
magazine reports that leopard print
Revival is upon us all right we're
seeing the trend being worn everywhere
from the red carpet to Casual street
style and it's a print that seems to
come back into our closets every few
decades leopard print yes let go yes I'm
surprised we hav we haven't worn leopard
print like I mean Le it's great I just
don't know if it's for for us I don't
know I don't know if that's something in
our
wheel WrestleMania our biggest outfit is
in I I might have a solution for you
guys why don't you just like add a pop
of leopard print to one of your outfits
and that way you don't have to go full
leopard in the
ring Dash
leard I can I can deal with that I
that's a great solution as a matter of
fact that gives me an idea what come on
wait hold let's huddle up for a second I
got an idea hold on
holda yes here's the idea Drew I would
like to make a request for you to be our
positivity coach SL Guru Senpai please
we want to take our levels of positivity
to the next
[Applause]
stratosphere
did we all just witnessed the birth of
Drew
Day Day and Drew day hold on hold on cuz
we do a special clap explain and we
usually say new day rocks however in the
honor of the new name and the new group
I think it's a probate that we say drew
Rock Drew Rock
[Applause]
okay now if it's okay I would love to
check in with you guys and I would love
nothing more than to do stuff with you
guys on our show on socials yes are you
in are you
in the honor would be online
and as your positivity coach I would
also really be honored if I could join
you guys in
Philadelphia it's in April it's in
Philadelphia and it's WrestleMania and I
want to
[Applause]
come uh you know what and I think what
what better way to seal the deal than to
have some matching tracks wow I'm let's
do it and um to see our exclusive track
suits you've got to head to our social
channels for the reveal um and I cannot
wait Big E Kofi Kingston Xavier Woods
The Amazing WWE Superstars thank you for
being here today thank you for letting
me come
your and after the break the ever
hilarious brilliant you know him for
Wedding Crashers you know her for just
from a bunch of she's the coolest she's
married to the coolest comedian on the
planet Isa Fisher here next we'll see
you guys in a minute